iv luke's ivy league schools are some of
the most competitive colleges in the
whole country
last year princeton university accepted
less than six percent of its applicants
yeah truly the cream of the crop
reporter kate houston spoke to a las
vegas student
who just got into the prestigious
university and shares his advice for
those who want to do the same
i remember started off with creating
like small little games which i would
show my friends
tyler vu started coding in middle school
by freshman year of high school he had
already completed the highest course
available
ap computer science it was like an
escape from reality at times but it was
also something where i could create
whatever my mind desires
wanting more accelerated courses he
attended csn high school where he could
work on his high school diploma
and an associate's degree i always try
to take challenging courses but i didn't
overwhelm myself with courses that i
felt were unnecessary
when applying to other colleges he used
questbridge
which connects high achieving students
from lower incomes
with some of the top colleges in the
nation such as princeton university
this admissions map shows only three
students out of the entire state of
nevada were accepted to princeton last
year
tyler vu will be joining them on a
full-ride scholarship
i think it allows me to have that
opportunity
and kind of be on that same playing
field no matter where i come from my dad
was really proud of me and i think
yeah that's really i think was one of
the best parts
vue hopes to create a startup with other
students after he graduates
then come back to las vegas to give back
to the community his advice for students
take specialized classes and stay driven
even if not getting top
grades i didn't get straight a's
throughout high school honestly it was
the fact that i was taking rigorous
courses and still challenged myself no
matter what
and i think that's something that made
me really stand out
kate houston eight news now he's like
yeah i got one a minus
one